yet another livestream I'm going to do
something but different I mean I'm going
to play some chess which is not
different but I'm going to play in that
how will do you rapid araignee which is
a rather long ride to us two hours
anyway let's get going and join this
tournament so it's a little bit more
relaxed jaw with ten minutes I have
never played this time controller
actually like ten minutes I actually
want to interrupt a friendly voice and I
always I wonder here if it is a good
idea to and to berserk every single game
it could be it could be an option okay
so I'm going to try something else here
against Yvonne Kovalenko got paired with
a number two seed trying this opening
here but we shouldn't be five really I
want to go see six anyway
it's quite um common what he's doing
okay I think b5 is is reasonable I don't
get that if he goes to b3 am I not just
going before the windows e4 pawn I mean
it's a it's a really important point I
don't see a tech tech working for him
like stuff on f7 for example oh yeah
whenever the bishop is on b3 you have to
keep in mind that f-7s somewhat under
pressure kind of weird
really okay before night anywhere 94
Queen j-3 I can go back I don't see it
I just don't said I'm going to try to
win that big pawn when he form there
should be five as a somewhat somewhat
strange idea yeah okay so what is even
Kovalenko up it up to him ten minutes no
increments it's really a bit of an off
time control or odd better wood yellow
to mercury in the chat so I'm taking
this home there's nothing really that
you can do yeah this one but I have
Knight to f6 or d5 actually d5 I play
this annoyed
well I can't can't do that there's
nothing really it's not a real issue
with this okay age three to stop any
Bishop g4 not sure that that was really
threatening this but okay
so what to do yeah he's got the moves
the Queen er than f3 and the night will
not have many squares a good movie has
certainly d5 simply giving more support
let's do that yeah hello to all of you
in the church and somehow I have to is
it possible to actually make the font
bigger here or something
it's not that I'm completely blind but
it's tough for me it's somewhat somewhat
somewhat smaller font to read so um
Bishop to f4 is developing yeah I think
I just go a 6 stabilize this and it's
not a big problem that membership is
fighting on granite I always have him
Bishop to a6 to activate it so this is
fine and this d5 d6 pawn wall makes it
efficient on
the focus of the pieces are unfocused
for me hmm
I don't know and it's a pretty normal
720p stream so the pieces should not be
unfocused
do you play bullet as well I do on
stream and not this time I mean this
tournament is going to be a bit a bit
slow I had 10 minutes and I want to have
a good mix of time controls so this is
something else going for 10 minute yeah
somebody said that the bottom wasn't so
well focused Newton I think um it's not
much that I can do here
I wonder if I did something wrong but I
don't I don't know what it could be the
stream is 720p I mean I could actually
stream in full HD like just looking at
them just looking at the connection
speed that I have but um I'd have to
check I guess somehow I couldn't set
that up when I was looking at setting up
to which it did not allow me to set full
a team
yeah the chess pieces seem unfocused I
don't know I mean they they they feel a
little bit blurry to me as well but they
do so on the screen I wonder maybe I can
maybe I should change the piece head
said actually that I use it's nothing
that I'm completely against I can I can
check this actually
I mean is it somewhere here how do I set
that out what editor no the settings
preferences no what what piece set I
have this piece set here yeah you know
that you know that yeah I think they
seem blurry as I seem blurry to me as
well I always use them but they are
blurry and sorry piece said this one
like this I can't sure I can do that and
see what happens
wait this
I don't know man browser zoom level 150
percent 150 percent is the browser's
moon level
should turn of the stylish theme in the
plug-in if you have that I do have that
yeah
uh-huh
now that you know they changed uh-huh
okay well I don't like those pieces Hey
that's what were to do you it I'll say
this this is better I like this better
hmm I have to get used to that it's a
bit different yeah they're sharper for
sure they're sharper but somehow I have
to check this
okay so I've lost a bit of time due to
the I lost a bit of time due to the
piece set thing okay I'm going to open
this position now the king is in the
middle of the board zone I should open
this up yep okay so let's see him I'm
not sure that this was some the best way
to play but again I wanted to make sure
that the position is actually opening up
okay so check and see where he goes I
can go to second takes e5 yes the
South's around 11 is going to be played
today who is going to win it this
tournament yeah that's a that's a tough
question because quite a number of
possibilities
I also think that
Carlton is the favorite so being the
best play of it so I'm not sure what is
the what is the what what color does he
have he's got black against my MIDI are
off probably now okay that that's
effective very interesting game of
course today yeah it's a 13 round event
important here in this game is that
there is no rookie one because I have
the check in with the big fork and no I
don't see white yeah defending this that
looks pretty ugly yeah thanks for the
follow
Elaine oh I've fixed why changed some of
some of the ozone the phones and so on
it should be should be getting better
and better everything a little bit step
by step the legs chess game no I don't
know what that is
sorry okay so I can check now here but
you know easy
I wonder what is easiest him if I check
here probably this is good yeah for
Queen h4 and Knight f4 stuff
white still has a hard time to play
rookie one as I've got Queen h4 no it's
very comfortable and I've even a pawn up
which is not the most important but it's
always some yeah nice to know that in
case you're not just winning by position
that you can now that you have the extra
material so night and I can still go
here
yeah let's line this up
I am Queen d6 to f4 is an idea one move
the knight but if I move the night
there's Ruby one so good job move the
Queen nearer
ya White has a bit of pressure here so
this is something I have to check out
not run into some some tactic or so on
f7 Bishop a4 yes okay g7 not much choice
and white wants to trade which is
understandable um okay I don't want to
trade I've got the safer King
okay now actually I could think of
trading because I have Knight c5 right
right after it yeah this will also be on
youtube of course every twitch stream
will be on youtube later so if you're
not going to be able to watch all of it
you can do so later on youtube yeah this
is actually something that I only really
registered when I had played everything
I mean not that it's so bad but I did
not want to go into a double room Nakia
okay so I'm going to try to fix the H
pawn if he goes h5 the Jeep on will be
weak I'm a good question will I get
eventually a subscriber option I already
have it so if you like to subscribe to
me Feynman you're happy - you're welcome
to do so it is possible now to just - to
subscribe to the twitch channel
[Music]
I'm with g6 I was making sure that the
h-bomb will never move but okay it's not
the only thing that I can do it's fairly
fairly comfortable because I have the
Lucas ideally placed on e5 yeah I'm
covering everything here and I've got
the kingpin down plus the Jeep owners on
the attack
yeah king of porn ending will be an easy
win if he decides to go for that yeah
thanks for a subscription
well so how do I actually win this game
him I think the easiest is probably for
me to walk towards the H pawn the a pawn
I'm sorry yeah I know I can take here
but this is probably easier
I just keep both pawns covered and run
to the a pawn
would be six are you saying on him I
can't
so probably have to do this after all
so what's them again what is the easiest
way probably to do this oh that's
surprising the team allows me to have
the two connected pawns so what is the
easiest way to do it to loop f5 just
keep everything covered we don't have
much time and just recognize that hmm I
have to this is actually an issue hey
after with this time control make sure
that you're not like falling asleep at
some point you have to increase the
speed
I'm a possum quite a bit quicker a five
I have King bee five I'm just stopping
this and then to promote this these two
points hello - no job chest
yes rapid game promoting my longer time
controls I mean long is relative now
we're not talking about correspondence
chess here but have a bit of time to to
think I don't know why this is a really
long game and I don't know probably I'm
not exactly leading in this tournament
yeah using all the time yeah but it's
it's what it is okay
okay yeah I'm father idea maybe I have
to really yeah
speed it up Sentaro mm probably you
could preserve every single game
oh he does Bozek okay come on we make it
blitz well that was a Muslim actually
I'm not playing the grope I'm really not
I don't like to play really bad openings
yeah it was a mouse slip the mouse the
mouse slipped French so the same okay
yeah the pieces are not sharper
absolutely no I don't classify the Dutch
as a dubious defense I don't I don't
really do I do understand why they don't
play it on the highest level all that
much but it's perfectly fine for for
regular use some buy by regular people
let's say
and now I have this Knight takes e5
checked it right why should work this
should work why does the Dutch have a
better reputation yeah well I think
mostly because it well it doesn't
develop exactly it's a bit bit slower in
development and f5 is a move that will
weaken your King King position for for
the rest of the game basically and this
is something that should not be
completely underestimated but it's not
me doesn't mean it is necessarily bad
but sometimes the positions are tough to
handle
do you understand eco codes do you mean
me I do I'm around for a long time so I
can identify the most openings by eco
code so a six wasn't really necessary
maybe I wanted to go on at c5 don't want
to see Queen B 5 but um my main point is
to be quick and hope to still win this
game want to catch up with the leaders
I have played the the Dutch Leningrad
forum for a while and my positions were
really good that I got it's um it's a
really quite sensible opening if you
want to if you want to go for
complications form yarn on symmetrical
positions from the get-go that that you
get with the with the Dutch a copy of
the EC oh oh yes I don't think I don't
have them anymore I had tons of them we
have the Hat I had or five ABCDE and
whatever even different editions but I
sold all the stuff some years ago really
figured okay you're never going to look
into them anymore
yeah in the if you look at the Dutch
there are a couple of sub variations of
course I like the leningrad most I think
this is the best of the variations maybe
but I also believe that the stormwater
is quite ok no I haven't thought about
playing a tournament in Norway because
currently I'm not focused so much on
playing anyway so hello to scheme art
not focused on playing that much anyway
going to yeah teaching more writing more
and so on but I don't play all that much
no there are no alpha0 games on my
stream not because I'm I don't know I'm
not interested and so on
but it was just it was a subject early
December when I was quite busy and so I
didn't didn't follow this so closely so
here I'm going to try to try to drum up
an attack just with the heavy pieces
because I have the seafoam rook g1 mer
the queen is not involved I only I only
do the lessons are always one on one and
one on one I'm sorry yeah I do teach you
my chess club of course which is which
is like a group of people but online
lessons are always one-on-one but I
don't take any new students at the
moment so Queen Jeff 5
and screen here him you're going to go
from the attack so is there a way to win
this him like rook h1 it looks it looks
really dubious okay I can also take and
the Queen f3 King up age 6 that should
also in this of course
intending g5 and Queen age 3 mate Wow
what he's got five games played five oh
my god if I want to win this I have to
probably go for a different strategy oh
my god so I have to basically berserk
every single game and try to try to win
quickly mm-hmm yeah Feynman Dirac thanks
for subscribing again and
hello to Tech's on 59 and thanks for
subscribing as well ok so I don't get a
game why is that give me a game ok Crom
calm do I really have to berserk hmm I
have to win basically so that makes it a
blitz tournament c4 actually that's a
bit more precise this is Tommy efficient
for some time so scheme are asked which
tournament I think is more interesting
Gibraltar or Mike um that's a very good
question
I still think why tansy but Gibraltar is
of course an extremely interesting
tournament chrome car I think has just
yeah got himself into into deep trouble
yeah got this fantastic pawn on d6
KF Hoya is the most yeah F was good most
direct way to do it
black takes a take f6
yeah that's true I could have tried to
keep c5 for the night but it's um this
is reasonably good yeah I think so I'm
how am I going to do this
what a funny position somehow like he's
six
no my queen here I would really like to
get rook F seven King f7 and rook F
seven queen of 76 Sonya it won't be
really cute but probably not not going
to work but if I step out of the check
it might work this one okay let's keep
it
easiest here's just two double-double on
the iPhone yeah maybe I could not play
look at seven I mean I tried to make
yeah spectacular moves work but if I see
something that is just completely
overwhelming like like the position here
I'm not looking all that hard it's
supposed to open this interesting
question its cards no bigger player now
compared to when he was 2 881 he had 40
40 M points higher rating at some point
yeah that's true
and I don't think he's weaker
necessarily which is a hard tough firm
good anyway for his his playing ability
but I think I'm in some in a bit term
the bit the others have caught up a
little bit at least a little bit but you
have to understand that 40 points
difference is not much I mean it's
really not much I always think about
this with my own rating and let's say
I'm 240 roughly to 430 something yeah if
that place somebody 40 points lower I
don't consider myself out writing the
other guy or the other way around if I
played 2500 I just think okay this guy
is just about the same as I am so yeah I
don't think this is a is a big
difference
yeah people challenge me
I'm going to decline there yes Steven
narcissism really but running away with
it but ya know I'm playing him and will
he be served me probably you will we
just resigned he just resigned the game
Wow
[Music]
I try to understand why you did that is
that good strategy to just resign if you
feel you're going to lose anyway
I'm two points behind him that's what
counts
yeah bye-bye at Exxon 59 so morning sun
is around okay it seems I have to but
that is a bit stupid we Adam okay
takes it yeah black has a couple of ways
to get the point back but it's a simple
and quite good so the MD d5 is good but
I wonder him what is the what is the way
to do it
d5 should be a very decent iqp because
because I've got in one in one move to
c5 I can also I can also set it up like
a head die like a head shrunk
Oh which is not maybe the most intuitive
way to do it but why not at least in the
actual I can play some quick moves yeah
by ski mod yeah watching Thomas steel is
certainly an attractive option now
to get to c5 I would not be five could
be an issue no it doesn't do it the
Hedgehog yeah I tend to say Hedgehog
yeah I don't know I got it almost
completed so I can do here I think I
will do that it's more active than 937
and I've got an immediate play against C
form Quincy seventy might just play c5
so I'm going to do here go here and here
maybe the other look to see one would
have been better so that you can put
rooks on D 1 and C 1
you know going to be 7s what I want to
do so he treats this okay hmm
interesting
yeah I can hmm yeah I'm thinking about
Knight to e4 in this person threatening
g5 g 5g form it's also threatens bishop
to have six it's actually interesting
Bishop f6 isn't annoying threat yet with
the Queen on b2 and the rook on a1 and I
have this g5 business like g5 bishop
moves g4 Knight moves and I have a heavy
discovery with with the night yeah so
let's get this on the road I think it
works this was especially unfortunate
for this kind of thing because s-92 with
the with an immediate threat on the
Queen that doesn't look good
just idea in case you're wondering about
the sound okay em what the heck it gives
me the peace okay give me the peace okay
I should save the night yeah this tactic
this tactic was coming somewhat
naturally with the with this thing with
this lineup so when when I put the Queen
D I was already thinking about some
tactical ideas I still have to be a bit
circumspect now I don't play in the Pro
chess league no not for a particular
reason I don't I don't have a team
simply okay prevent Bishop g5 if
somebody feels I could play on their
team I'm not sure about the rules and
give me a message I'm happy to discuss
that I had 94 mercury says yes that is
very much possible yes you're right
actually now only now see that I'm
really quite a bit behind on the clock
so I have to be a bit a bit quicker
[Music]
yeah I've got a good look there on c4
and 94 was a good move some some months
ago when the king was still on g2 now I
think it's nothing nothing special
hmm maybe I should have taken with with
the deep on to make 95 possible
okay I want to put the bishop on to g7
that's the best Square for it please
turn off sound for follow notification I
like the sound you think it's a huge
distraction
okay so how do I actually promote stuff
this way not to be a bit cautious in I
have to think about it I'm not sure I
have those sounds on they are there by
default but I never I never put much
thought into it if they're distracting
or not yeah Luke t5 and d3 is the main
point and of course to take the pawn
here if he just gives me the pawn give
it to me the pawn as yesa tends to say
ok Queen to b6
I can actually take and grab it at the
end my pawns will will win yeah bit too
many I can pre move d1 now almost okay
so I've taken the lead
Steve analysis has lost three now so we
had a really great run at the very
beginning but somehow lost a bit of
steam okay so I didn't deserve that one
yeah because he resigned okay IC came so
I should get a new pairing super Babu
nullity asked do you watch the st. Louis
chess videos um I do sometimes didn't do
so much recently they have many new
presenters that I don't know I mean it's
not like I'm not saying they're bad I
simply didn't watch I am
I sometimes watch them when they have
Sara Warren or somebody a little bit out
of the ordinary that you don't see every
every other day but I don't watch her
regularly
okay I tried something else here against
hacker I play the the check we known him
very closed position I know that looks
passive but it actually is an odd black
is actually playing something reasonably
ambitious keeps everything closed no
trades and tries to break with I forgot
to berserk yeah I forgot to berserk okay
so again a very close position I try to
still play pawn to b5 y-term of course
can try to play em for before as well
yeah I wonder if I can actually ever
manage to play with five no going to be
difficult
it's going to be really difficult 94 is
now something that he has to do
something about
yeah that was to be expected
I got b5 now but that is not not that
great
who not that's not really nice I should
have thought about the director for a
little bit more I can go be five but
well I'm not threatening much with that
he can take one son be five even play
just be three after No
I know that looks sick but I think that
real issue was performed that I got into
this position in the first place it
doesn't really look good if he takes
only five at least I get the d6 square
for the night that was one idea of 98
but I doubt that he will take I think
white would rather try to mmm something
like I do okay I was very quickly
decided
okay
okay I have night - a six and then be
formed potentially 95 what I can take on
F form and play Bishop f6 but then it
will grip on b5 night it six rook takes
b5 but also possible yeah not good
Spector's rupee one I should make more
videos against cheetahs okay now I
understand that some of them like that
they can be entertaining at times but I
can assure you they're not entertaining
to play always feels like an entire like
a complete waste that same so night to
see seven I guess I am NOT Sherman night
a seven maybe a bit and that probably
taking us right
member garethw Calvin game is very open
after 11 moves no C&D pawns that doesn't
sound too interesting and it's possible
that this is a pretty pretty lame draw
this game or that could could turn out
to be a pretty lame draw a draw isn't
bad for both of them actually
cousin but black okay and you draw is
usually okay with black and moment you
are off yeah the draw is also fine
taking on you five yeah I'm going to
take on b5 then I think I'm okay no okay
now Queen cheeks
the night has a good spot on c5 nobody
are off still has a very dynamic
playing style I don't think he's changed
much there well interview said he
doesn't drink any alcohol anymore which
can be a huge factor actually if you I'm
not sure how much he was some he was
drinking before that change but it
doesn't help I mean I mean if you drink
if he was really drinking a lot it's
extremely harmful and even a little bit
it's a problem let's say I mean you're
just not getting to 100% in the meantime
I'm getting to c3 and that should win
some material
so I'm winning the exchange here yeah
hello - piece of sheet so how do i how
do I get into conversion here Bishop f6
you should have six bishop t 425 yeah
that's really funny I don't know if it
actually helps it's the problem I think
it's good if no it doesn't get e5 we
should be for Queen c5 I might take on
c5 Bishop c3 Bishop d6 I could work
yeah so it's an exchange for porn and
let's do this I'm actually not so sure
about Queen b6 maybe I should have
thought about it a bit more because you
could argue that I actually have the
better King position so shouldn't trade
yeah but ultimately it is material
Bishop g4 will trade even more yeah I
should be able to win one of the points
that way but I should not allow
definitely is losing I'm losing d6 maybe
this is a good square asking white about
his next move
no ninety form well it's a bit annoying
if where does he go in the king moved us
Ruby three probably yeah so let's stop
any 93 f5 stuff
the edge e3 Roxy 392 rookie three will
probably win some stuff another typical
way to win with the rook against the
nidus domination yeah
okay anchor twenty-nine reasons Ella
borrow me is winning here a lot it's
tough it's tough to win you can win all
the games and still somebody is working
every single time and going to okay the
Kings gambit you want to see me not win
this what kind of message is that
[Music]
why do you decline my challenge you are
afraid of me
well I'm in a tournament what can I do I
cannot I cannot play two games at this
two games at the same time I think
okay so what's going on here he's
looking at see for years so probably I
need to cover that porn not black was
threatening to check here and here so
now I'm not deserving a blocking of just
I want the friendly messages it's okay
any new challenges is he changing me
again
yes yes I can decline that again that's
good so box cat is considering the
options okay if the f3 OHV aren't
interesting yeah I guess f3 it's a bit
surprising
isn't that what is the the real point
here
I know it's a bit greedy but if she give
me a pawn I'm taking it gift me the pawn
I came I wonder here
isn't that a move maybe
it's agent GL agent GL is strong kids
really I have played a have played a
bullet match against him not too long
ago like week ago yeah last last week I
think and it was several interesting I
was winning this fee and iam very
clearly but it was really tough I had to
be really oh really yeah my the night
only for is strong but his night is also
a bit of a nuisance so I'm trying to
trade it off I still have to get my
queen back and I would like to put it on
to d4 of course d4 has a really good
square
yeah box cat is thinking about it I
don't know as much else compare I was
taking it him
yeah black house I guess no compensation
here for the porn one problem long-term
is that those will gain weekend rupee
one and so on
yeah I think probably would be five is
this idea but I have come to different
chick okay where are you going it's
ecology form yeah I prefer to stream on
Twitch I've done a bit of streams on
YouTube which with twitches giving more
options ready and one thing that is
definitely important I mean is that
twitch allows the subscriptions and I
need to yeah think a bit about how much
time to invest in the streams and if I
can earn a bit of money at least with
them it makes it possible to stream more
often yeah I'd like to do it but it's a
it's a matter of it's a matter of
possibilities financially if yeah if you
give me like 1000 subscribers I'm going
to stream every single day of the week
for some hours but probably not going to
get get people thousand but getting if
you would be would be still very nice
and yeah would be a great incentive to
stream warm so I'm going to go here
forward double check okay it's got Roxy
seven yeah well this one but this gives
me a new target on d6 okay
legs felt which has almost three
thousand subs
isn't that a cougar player I think it's
a poker player right I mean it's been a
while since I've followed poker but it's
a poker feel I'm free all right
he I'm trying to put pressure on both
pawns and I should win one of them so I
think yeah like a not avoided and box
get resigned and five points behind Elba
Rogge can you give me place the pairing
el buro each has explained I would
really like to see that
oh so I'm committed to this wacky gambit
because I basically pre move yeah I
forgot to do Zerg of course and
yeah Bishop Bishop c4 is actually a bad
move but I have to think about it for a
moment and f6 and d5 is strong yeah
26:26 is a simple way to do it I wonder
if I can go for sacrifices Knight f6
Knight takes c6 pawn takes Bishop takes
Bishop d7 Bishop a and Queenie and let's
close its close
hmmm I wonder if Bishop d7 as a mafia
Bishop d7 now a queen age v g6 Knight
takes Knight f6 Queen back takes on g6
Queen age 894 Bishop d7 King that is a
compensation it's extremely wacky word
let's do it
he plays this and this is of course a
better choice I overlooked that simple
move how stupid
yeah I was stupid I could have just
played Queen d6 and I'm fine
and now Queen h5 is probably going to
kill me okay yeah okay Knight f6 now
that screen to e5 is the problem so I
have to take this yeah white is better
now of course it's still not it's still
not super clear because I've been better
developed and
tries to play a 5 maybe okay I need to
get long castles in chess network has
been low 225 subscribers uh-huh
how can you find that out it's hard to
believe that there's just this small
amount with 75,000 people following and
plus is spamming every single social
media platform that there's available so
should I shoot me more you would think
so what is this if I take there's a
check which is not a big deal I have
keep making its own
no I didn't know that he's dreaming only
every two weeks okay
let's see how to
Oh get a rook h8 night h5 stuff like
that
get the Knight to f5
I still take a seven oh okay
huh
it's a strange move but it is probably
good I have a hard time I have a hard
time to quit Queenie six I have to do it
it's just look yeah just a move that you
don't like to play so here
what no I didn't coach Kings crusher for
tournament in London what kind of idea
is that
that's not you
so Bishop a6 is keeping the Queen out I
need to check it to win it
I met trifon in I met him in fact in 20
2013 when I was visiting the candidates
in London we met at at the candidates
tournament and maybe this is where this
idea is coming from so how do I actually
win the Queen magic voice an idea Bishop
before a 5 B 6
but the moment I go Bishop a5 there is
Queen to c5 so how can I can't go Knight
d7 and then try to play Knight to c6 at
the end I don't know it looks a bit
weird to be honest
yeah but maybe this is right it's right
at the end trying to track the Queen
Queen a3 was a debatable move right him
Knight b6 mmm King D 7 okay it is also
possible I think he wants to play Knight
to c5 right mmm true
Knight b3 to c5 hmm interesting tough
it's really tough 93 96 no to c5 hmm I
cannot think unfortunately like 93 96 95
Bishop c5 Quincey file okay
so King de 7 yeah Knight b6 rook a a
that what's the alternative for sure now
I actually think I haven't wrapped I
know I don't think how he how he talks
himself out of this now
and that's the queen so I won this queen
that's good let's see how to how to win
this night five I guess still a bit of
work I mean I'm a piece up actually I'm
because I was quite substantial material
down to begin with yeah it would be
funny yeah doing some completely weird
comments here hope that the opponent
listens in and then is totally irritated
it's a really funny idea try to go for a
night two am sorry Queen to g4 go for
mate
that's going to be difficult to meet
Quincy form I still forgot to preserve
this hmm oh that's actually an
interesting move um yeah I can still go
Quincy form which will win a bit of
material 93 is the second and the second
threat so I'm going to win more stuff
come on you really playing this on I
have four minutes on the clock okay at
least you were assigned next step okay
so okay desert back okay
in this runs into into this for trick
naughty five because he takes it this is
an important little tactic he five takes
pawn takes Queen b6 and made some let's
avoid dad
okie-dokie 95 Black has to return to d8
but this intending look everyone also
looks pretty good
so what take a look at her 7 year 95
actually also was pretty good
to see if Wow I was thinking I was
thinking Queenie ADIS they only move
essentially Queen to G form it is really
close to a queen trap can I trap the
Queen age three maybe
of course the rook is hanging but if I
can trap the Queen Edward turn probably
encourage and courage resignation let's
see Quincy 392 and this should be played
with the sound of door slamming that was
the Queen I think I don't see I don't
see a square ah hello P nephew dog so we
met in Battersea last yest yeah that's
great that was a really cool event right
I hope we will do that in 2018 again
when where was some late late November
yeah and you know the same time if I
take the rook cruise just way for him to
escape I don't think so the World
Championship match maybe is a good way a
good time to repeat this event so the
world championships will be in London
Queen is still completely trapped
[Music]
okay I'm not taking now yeah okay I'll -
I'll take the Queen I just take
everything
would really help to resign no yeah the
thing is I'm always a little bit annoyed
in those arena formats if people don't
resign when have I mean no it's a queen
down and I've got more time everything
and it just hurts a bit yeah I won that
blitz tournament and in the palace see
chess club and I overtook a biragi and
his past was he paused hmm anyway would
be cool to get paired and hopefully beat
the guy borrow me from Egypt somebody
asked about the Dutch defence so let's
play the Dutch defence o g4 but the heck
crisis asked did I stop to produce
videos isn't that a video that I'm
producing here what I'm doing is simply
every video is done on Twitch why not so
it will always be live people can ask me
questions and there is more interaction
but still it will be a video on YouTube
so I think this is a good way of doing
it there also will be other formats than
simply me playing I'm thinking about the
Q&A format um in fact this is probably
something that will be installed in in
rather short autumn so what's going on
here
he castles so if I click here what is he
doing taking on c6 taking on deform it's
all hard to believe
the only good thing is for white
observed and with the buzzer King
playing unconventional positions is
always a bit extra tricky in those Reena
formats I think if you are really like
down counts of material and they have no
chance to to win on time resigning is
actually pretty good idea
it's just that yeah you really hamper
both both players chances actually okay
Bishop c5 now to line up against this um
okay so if I go D three
that's probably Bishop e3 coming okay
let's just see what happens here okay I
can even play h5 it's not a bad idea
like to develop of course but sharp t7
simply I don't know it's a bit of a late
movie it's a bit lame
some hot time ok let's do it let's do it
it's probably right just go go for an
attack
okay so f2 is actually hanging
or Queen age form of teenage Falls it
looks good Bishop d6 M is the most
direct way but I just spotted if white
girl place the F pawn I cannot even take
[Music]
what Siri what are you doing here
[Laughter]
sometimes during the commentary I say
something that activates Syria sometimes
I think it's when I say serious anyway
okay so how is white going to play that
I strongly expect a check Queen b3
so Bishop d6 let's do it
F form I have g3 actually
yeah
it sometimes happens that that Syria
gets activated during my English lessons
I don't know I think serious is some
OTCs he chess is now hosting my stream
with 530 viewers it sounds like a lot so
I got lots more viewers I said to set
the case Wow I would be cool yeah so
Luke takes f2 probably Queens you you
won
for a pin oh I didn't see that one
coming
I mean I can take it - it's not a huge
deal okay and now I [ __ ] a chick and
tempo Bishop g6 maybe hmm there should
be six maybe okay I've got Ruby five and
stuff but just maybe Bishop just Ruby to
him rookie - it's a good move for rook H
- I use xsplit I know that it seems so
many streamers prefer what is called OBS
but I started out with exploit and it
does the job at the moment they have not
looked into into alternatives so what's
going on here night c4 or something
how many pawns actually seven right I'm
seven points up
no I'm three points up seven points up
would be really really a lot
I can't some mmm take this
xplit seemed very few chewy
food surely as an interesting word what
is foolery you mean you have to do
things like him very menu Leo I know it
was just the first program that I came
across at the time and I still use it
mmm fiddly or awkward hmm
yeah it is a bit fiddly that's probably
true
[Music]
I can play d3 the whole time and somehow
I have ignored this possibility and now
I'm going to take this
yeah pawn is peasant yeah actually also
translate to simply to farm yeah the guy
running a farm so em what's going on
here this one for Bishop III yes so I
think I'm going to promote the C pawn
hooray promote to the farm i young
actually if I go Bishop III and he will
take this because at the end s Bishop
before check aha
okay
it should be three bishop hmm no of
course cannot copy should be three I
played Bishop f3 and I'm going to win
the house soon so King age six was
actually okay
yeah Bishop a3 I cannot do much about it
Bishop b3 a half Bishop every check out
because him checking here King g1 hopes
King g1 Bishop c5 white is running out
of Muslim
you know what is playing according to
Larry Christensen's motto never resign
as long as you have annoyed which is
kind of true in in the in blitz chess or
bullet even okay so you can check here
first no one doesn't make a difference I
guess I don't think it does
yeah and he will probably continue this
even he will oh my god
yeah let's try to be as quickly as
possible okay I've got 51 seconds which
is kind of at least a little bit like
time trouble double threat
according to Larry you have to resign
now yeah when you lose your knight you
have to resign
he doesn't
least I can pre move a lot and there is
absolutely not
stay away coming
okay so I did win this thing
but Romi is serve is pausing and really
irritating maybe you really got
interrupted or something
so I'm five points ahead and now it
looks like I am a box cat again
okay so before I played on before I'm
not I don't know that I played the same
opening oh thanks for the subscription
silky McNuggets okay so now prom it's
good to check the pomace like that
um okay box cat is playing really
quickly here
hmm hmm maybe I did something wrong yeah
yeah it's possible looks
he just blitz it out I need some emo
what say oh I need to need to look at
this shoot huh what did I do wrong
that looks like I'm in it looks a bit if
he here made my position
very strange very strange yeah in terms
of coming shows it's very likely there
will be a Monday show of course that
will be regularly anyway and very nice
if I have any file actually I'm very
likely very likely I will do I will
install basically a weekly show on on
Tuesdays very likely Tuesdays at 5 p.m.
6 p.m.
something like that this is an open
timeslot at the moment in my schedule
and very likely this will be a weekly
show as well
hey Willie gassy mode guys to be honest
I don't even know what an e mode is I
know it is probably the little picture
that you can post this but yeah yeah
that's those pictures but I have to work
on that
okay so what i'm doing here is i'm
attacking c4 so b7 is basically hanging
which was not at all answered public so
I'll take it
so at the end this is falling and Knight
takes e4 doesn't doesn't work
ravu has subscribed thank you so this is
not not so easy yet to be perfectly
honest at least from my abilities it's
not so easy
um okay I think rocky one covering a
four-night c5 I'll take is 7 let's see
him and I'm now threatening to play I
think Bishop b3 okay so here I will take
is 7 but at the same time cover C form
and he cannot take a 4 because of Bishop
b3 so okay and box CAD resigned that
turned out to be disastrous somehow the
beginning I felt I was growing up to me
water somehow but maybe not so it looks
like I'm going to win this there's 14
minutes left
yeah pending emotes yeah I have to check
this are the emotes actually there never
are they moving I mean it said like like
a gift file or it said just a picture
yeah I don't know I forgot to berserk
but maybe I deserve a little bit of a
little bit of a slow game okay no color
which what are you doing him this is a
yeah I was thinking I wanted to look him
at vibe positions for a second after the
stream not for so long but a bit really
that is going to work hmm you guys
probably know that I don't believe in
this stuff okay if you get emotes I
would say yeah I would definitely make
some okay so f3 is the thing yeah f3 but
I am king of Sam I mean
so on the screen f3 yet still it is
still slightly working
rook e8 queen h5 now
it's not so easy it's not super easy
25 I'm thinking Queen f3 Bishop f5
this is preventing Queen to h5 yeah I
was thinking this should work rook is 7
I will take with the night look f4 I'm
not threatening much of Queen takes I'm
not threatening to take with the Queen
so that's definitely true
mmm interesting
interesting like rook here okay now rook
e8 rook chicks the eight is actually an
issue Queen takes f3 rook takes h8 and
then there's check on but it should work
g4 head Queen check see form so this
wasn't an issue
I can loop here and they still look is
seven somehow Knight takes rook checks
okay so there is a chick but the promise
the queen is hanging so if I do this I
do this I should be safe right covering
the Queen
yeah
g4 of course I forgot about this I
completely forgot about the movie
this freeing crap I'm so I really hate
hate to be in trouble against openings
that just lose a piece yeah I forgot
about gee foyer of all moves this is so
so utterly annoying really annoying they
don't even have a good movie
that is pretty pretty it's pretty
terrible after pawn takes King EA that
is even Rukia Geum
yeah just totally lost this position it
just lost
it's just lost now whatever I don't care
[Music]
okay yeah I wonder what I did wrong I
mean here this is I don't believe that
just Jesus six King g7 maybe or so I
don't know I mean you know it's it's
friggin no it'sit's Blitzer or rapid or
whatever yeah this wasn't even good it
wasn't even good so um let's see can I
stick in a somehow or save this game
No yeah
whatever making chicken Queeny for
actually no
yeah unfortunately everything wins it's
impossible to screw it up with all that
all those pawns
yeah they cannot cannot keep the
material okay I didn't really pay
attention anymore I mean it's just sick
stick to get into any any sort of
trouble down I should probably go g6 and
this and this in this in this position
and not queen defy queen e5 looked okay
but maybe it was technically technically
too too unreliable that same
is that somewhat interesting probably
not young
she's seven
okay gg7 rook to g6 is getting a game
again yeah we get four it's not going to
be a dryer I have some I have some
chicks but so this this [ __ ] opening
was somewhat somewhat working you really
interesting Queen d7 will win I didn't
doesn't see a single win no what
okay that also wins it's unfortunately
so lost that I can play many substandard
moves and so in okay so what so this is
not winning from like a this is crazy
why can't play this nonsense how many
how many if we gambits are they I am I
mean okay you can just play whatever and
be a partner but yeah I cannot take that
piece and win that's it's crazy it's
really crazy
twenty five
that's remarkable remarkable how many
are many completely idiotic looking
lines they are that some somehow still
work him really strange
okay I saw one that tournament even
though I hate to lose this game the
final game after this Viera opening um
okay so let's what what is what's the
clock 3 in 3 p.m. so we can have a look
at the broadcasts and see what's going
on here so in the crucial game Omidyar
of Carlton okay they have a very dry
line on the board animals only with
greedy 5 yeah this is a good line for
for black as currently I think no clear
recipe for white down and we have
substantial some simplifications okay to
bishops against two nights but night
before is going to get one again one of
the bishops yeah okay that's extremely
dry
let me check yeah uh sorry I'm sorry
guys but this irritates me um yeah look
before I guess him night a jewelers okay
one that looks a bit iffy well okay I
would be very surprised that would end
in a draw when we have koala giri how
did that happen well that was in London
system so basically in not very
theoretical opening mum yellow plate 92
six
I was that just a line okay so this is
the actual position okay and that's also
extremely dry even if white would retain
the two bishops and so on it's a this is
not a position where the bishop pair is
super strong because the complete
symmetry very difficult to make
something happen with a completely
symmetrical instruction so Caruana giri
mia Thiam white white has a nice
advantage in space yeah equal ish but I
would prefer white I guess kayaking
Kramnik it was that was an English I
ready ready opening yeah also equal ish
I guess and Anand who your font is a sim
scimitar front no was the Queens gambit
declined with 95 it's kind of a cemetery
chef
you know this is the typical play with
the deep horn yeah this is like between
equal and slightly better for white Rd
burn ye we have a closed English yeah
probably also equal ish Matlock or
sweetly is this is a duel between two
friends and yeah mates that that work
together so those always slightly tricky
if you know the other guy really well
and what was that so against Jones make
two points
unconventional opening here be a seven
cream be true and it's a really really
weird position but I think that white
should be better him
yeah the B group is there a particular
interests in any be group game I will
put a shop check how the German player
Matisse blue bomb is doing against
Gordievsky 2600 play I never heard of so
95 yeah it's also about equal so yeah
I'm very confident in predicting a draw
on the very first bought they will
probably play a bit but you know I think
very likely a draw the drunken lawyer
says he has to go to the kids training
yeah and to be honest I have to do the
same we have our kid
and the chips club in roughly 18 minutes
90 minutes and I have to do some stuff
before so I have to run as well thanks a
lot for watching the stream I hope you
enjoyed it I will definitely be back on
Monday very likely on Tuesday I might do
something on Saturday
it depends some on on some some prep
issues yeah for Sunday a player have a
leak a.m. on Sunday and if I don't have
I don't need to prep that much I will do
a stream thanks a lot guys
bye bye